[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so remember from last lecture that we
wanted to solve a generic system of
differential equations x dot equals ax
where X is a vector and a is a matrix
I've stopped drawing under bars to
denote matrices and vectors I hope you
know that X is a vector and a is a
matrix
to solve this generic system x dot
equals ax what we're trying to do is
diagonalize it which means we want to
find a new coordinate system a change of
coordinates into a new coordinate system
Z so that Z dot equals a diagonal matrix
times Z because it's much much easier to
solve this differential equation where D
is diagonal then this differential
equation where a is kind of a generic
gnarly Matrix
and so we're literally trying to find
this Matrix T that is a change of
coordinates between x and z where it
makes my Dynamics easier we're trying to
find that coordinate transformation T
and in the last lecture I derived I
showed
that the Matrix T that diagonalizes my
system is specifically The Matrix T from
this eigenvalue problem and so in this
um
expression a is my original Matrix
T is a matrix of eigenvectors of A and D
is a diagonal matrix of eigenvalues of a
so I'll just write this out so these um
diagonal entries diagonal
entries
are eigenvalues
this is a German word I'll tell you
about in a minute eigen and the columns
Columns of t
are my eigenvectors
and so instead of thinking about this as
a matrix eigenvalue problem it's
sometimes a little easier to just think
about finding individual eigenvectors
and eigenvalues one at a time so kind of
columns of T and entries of D you know
finding those one at a time and so uh
the way I'm going to write that is
um
this a x
equals
Lambda X okay so the the German word
eigen literally means like special or
characteristic it actually in in German
it means latent or characteristic I'm
going to write this down so like uh
eigen
eigen means
latent
or characteristic
what that means is kind of like the
essence of it's the essence of something
so if you like boil off everything else
the latent or the characteristic part is
what's going to remain the eigen part so
you'll notice my channel is called
eigensteve I'm Igan Steve eigen just uh
and also I guess when I think of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors I'm
thinking these are kind of special
values and special vectors I'm going to
Define what I mean by special in a
minute
um but ax equals Lambda x for
special
vectors X
and for
special
values Lambda and that's kind of what I
mean uh is that these X are going to be
eigenvectors those are special values
special vectors where this is true and
Lambda are special numbers where this is
true not all Lambda are going to satisfy
this equation and not all vectors X can
satisfy this equation only very special
vectors X and special vectors Lambda can
satisfy this
um
good
and this is the eigenvalue equation for
a single pair X comma Lambda so this is
the eigen
value equation
for a specific pair for a pair
of eigenvalues and eigenvectors X comma
Lambda so they always come in pairs an
eigenvector always has an eigenvalue
Associated and an eigenvalue always has
an eigenvector Associated to it okay so
this is what I'm going to talk about
today in this lecture I'm going to give
you some numerical not not numerical by
hand examples we're going to actually
compute these special vectors X and
special values Lambda for a particular a
matrix that I'm going to write down
and then we're going to talk about how
to compute these in general for an
arbitrary Matrix a
now what I want
is my definition
uh
easy to understand I guess is what I
want to say
what I mean by special
is that there are special vectors X that
when I multiply them by this Matrix a
the direction of X doesn't change it
just gets scaled up or down by Lambda so
what I mean here is that um
multiplication by a matrix I usually
think of that as a coordinate
transformation so vectors when you
multiply them by matrices typically
they'll you know rotate and maybe
stretch and they deform so you can take
all of your your vectors in X and when
you multiply them by a it's going to
kind of rotate and deform generically
those vectors and there are some very
special vectors X that when you multiply
them by a they don't rotate they just
get longer or shorter and that's what I
mean by these eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so that's the example I'm
about to show you maybe I'll move my
notes over here so I have some room so
let's just do an example to get some
intuition and then we'll talk about this
in the generic case
so an example
a matrix I'm going to pick an a matrix
that is 3 minus 1 minus one three three
minus 1 minus one three just a little
simple two by two a matrix but it's not
diagonal so it's going to be difficult
to you know do solve differential
equations with this a matrix and so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to try
like a random X Vector I'm going to just
pluck an X Vector out of a hat multiply
it by a and see if it satisfies this
equation okay so we're going to try
um
let's try x equals
um you know 1 0 that's kind of the
easiest thing we can try let's try x
equals one zero
and I'm trying to think of
how I want to draw this because I'm
going to draw you a picture but let's
try x equals 1 0.
then ax
ax is going to equal I literally can
just multiply a times x and it's going
to be 3 negative 1. this is 3 negative
1.
okay and clearly you can see that a
times X is not just x times some number
it's not just X longer or shorter they
point in different directions completely
different directions
so I'm going to draw a picture
um
and I want to be very careful about what
colors I use otherwise this is going to
get impossibly messy
so let's say
um
I have my
my X1
and x two axes here and my first test
Vector maybe I'll draw some ticks you
know one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven
I could do this in a computer but I
think it's way more fun uh to do it by
hand this is how I always think about it
so what I literally did here is I took
this test Vector this test Vector X
this Vector one comma zero you know it's
one in this direction zero in this
direction and I multiplied it by a and I
got something that was
um
one two three negative one so I got
something that points in a completely
different direction this was X
and this was a x they point in
completely different directions so they
can't possibly be eigenvectors or I you
know eigenvectors of the system
good um let me try one other example
just you know to illustrate let's try x
equals
0 1 so now instead of pointing in the X
Direction it's going to point in the
kind of X the X1 directional point in
the X2 Direction
um again I can multiply this by a and I
get a x equals
now it's going to be negative one three
so that's negative 1 3
uh that means that I'll pick a different
little color here I'll just do yellow
because they're kind of pretty similar
yellow and green so now this little uh
Vector here
multiplies to negative 1 1 2 3.
again
different directions so my Vector
rotated after multiplication by a and so
neither of these kind of principal X1 or
X2 directions are eigenvectors of my a
matrix these are not eigenvectors
so there are special vectors I haven't
convinced you yet probably that there
are in fact these magic vectors where
this is true so what I'm going to do is
I'm actually just going to write them
down I'm not going to derive them yet
I'm just going to write them down show
you that they have this property and
then I'm going to show you how to solve
for them if you if you had this a matrix
and I'm going to do this in blue
and pink so the first Special Value is
I'm going to claim that the first
special
and sometimes I call my eigenvectors C
sometimes I like to use my fancy pants C
Vector here because I really like C C
and I are old friends and the first
eigenvector is going to point in the one
One Direction okay this is I claim an
eigenvector let's see if this is true so
I'm going to multiply this by a
I'm going to take a
times C
what happens when I multiply a by 1 1 I
get 3 minus 1 is 2 and minus 1 plus 3 is
also 2. so this equals
2
2.
and lo and behold this actually is in
the same direction as C it's exactly two
times bigger than c x stretched C by a
factor of two so this is my Lambda 1
equals two
okay so a times C is equal to 2 times C
that's good so I'm going to draw this
picture so this Vector here in the 1 1
Direction
this C
is an eigenvector because when I
multiply it by a
I get a vector in the exact same
direction a times C1 equals 2 times C1
this was C1
so that's really really special that's
what I mean by an eigenvector they're
special kind of magic directions where
if I take a vector in that direction and
I multiply it by a that Vector stays in
that direction very very interesting
very very important and you can almost
picture how those special directions
where If I multiply by a things stay in
that direction that's how I'm going to
decouple my Dynamics because in these
directions
uh my Dynamics are completely decoupled
in this direction and in the other
direction I'll get back to that later so
that's one special eigenvector
see the next special eigenvector
my next special C2 I believe it's going
to be like 1 minus one or something like
that so it's 1 minus one I'm I've had a
lot of experience with eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and almost you can read
these off of the two by two Matrix
but you'll get there if you can't do
that already let's multiply a by this
now
and so now I'm going to multiply it and
I get
3 minus minus 1 is 4 and
minus 1 minus 3 is minus four so I get 4
minus four
again this is just a constant scaling of
C2 sorry I should have written that this
is a
times C2 that's what this 4 negative 4
is and so my Lambda 2 equals
four
okay so I can again draw this one so I
take a step one in the first Direction
and minus one in that direction that's
uh C2 and If I multiply it by a I get I
take one two three four steps one two
three four steps
and this is a times C2 and that just
equals four
times C2 so there are in fact these very
special kind of eigen directions these
eigenvectors X I call them C1 and C2
here these pink and blue directions
where If I multiply those very special
vectors by my a matrix I get a vector in
the same direction in the same direction
that's just scaled by Lambda in this
case Lambda 2 in this case Lambda 4.
okay and I think I showed you and I
convince you if I just randomly pick a
vector and I multiply it by a it's going
to rotate it's going to go into a
different direction so not all vectors X
are eigenvectors only very special
vectors are eigenvectors that have this
property
good
Oakley two eigenvalues and two
eigenvectors for this two by two system
um I'm just telling you that's true
right now we'll see that that's true in
a minute okay there's exactly two
um there's two kind of eigen
vectors
and values
good and again they come in pairs this
is the eigenvalue corresponding to this
eigenvector and similarly this is the
eigenvector corresponding to this
eigenvalue they come paired up that's
why I color coded them
okay good so hopefully this builds your
intuition now what I'm going to do is
you know this is just one example for
one a matrix that's not that generic so
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you how to solve for these
eigenvalues and eigenvectors for a
generic Matrix okay so now we're going
to go
um and how to do this in general so I'm
going to erase all of this and then
we're going to work that out
okay
so
I've given you some examples of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors now I'm
going to show you how to solve for them
in general someone gives you a random a
matrix you're going to be able to figure
out what are the special X and lambdas
that are eigenvalues and eigenvectors
so I'm literally going to take this
equation here and I'm just going to
rewrite it a little bit so I'm going to
say that and I want to give myself a
little space here I'm sure I'm going to
need it
so I'm going to say that a
x equals Lambda X
you can always do this with with
matrices you can say that Lambda just a
number times a vector X is the same as
that number Lambda times the identity
Matrix times x because any Vector X is
just the identity Matrix times that
Vector X so I can little you know pop
into Matrix I here if you are confused
by that pause
and you know write this out with an
identity Matrix times x and convince
yourself that that is exactly just X
it's totally fine and so essentially now
I can move this the reason I'm doing
this is because now I can move this over
to the left hand side and I have Matrix
a matrix Lambda I times Vector X so I
can move this over to the left hand side
and say a minus Lambda times the
identity Matrix
x equals zero this is equivalent to my
eigenvalue problem here this is an
equivalent way of writing it
uh and again you know X is a vector zero
it's a vector of zeros a and I are
matrices I'll just put them here so you
remember n Lambda is a number
and so what we're trying to do is we're
trying to find X and Lambda pairs of X
and Lambda that satisfy this equation
now you might imagine well this is easy
I'll just make x equals zero and then
this is always true that is technically
mathematically true but that's kind of
boring
um it's not really a vector x equals
zero is not a vector it has zero length
and so I'll just write down you know
case one
uh x equals zero is kind of a solution
but it's not very interesting it's not
uh it's not what we're looking for
interesting these are not the droids
you're looking for okay not the
eigenvectors you're looking for case two
is more interesting
so case two the other way that this can
be equal to zero is
for X to not be zero
and for this Matrix to be what's called
singular meaning it Maps certain vectors
to zero okay I'm going to write this out
and then I'm going to explain it so case
two is where X is not zero
and the determinant
of a minus Lambda I
equals zero if the determinant of a
minus Lambda I equals zero that means
there are some directions where this
Matrix will map those directions to zero
okay I'll draw you a picture later just
take my word for it for now that's what
this means is that if I have a matrix a
minus Lambda I with determinant 0 there
are certain subspaces certain directions
that if I multiplied them by that I
would get 0 which is kind of what I'm
looking for I'm looking for an A minus
Lambda I where there's directions that
map to zero okay so that's kind of what
I'm looking for
um
in this case we we call this singular we
say
a minus Lambda I
is singular
I put my air quotes on the wrong thing a
minus Lambda I is singular that that's
just the words we use in math to
describe this and that means uh meaning
it Maps
some vectors some Vector some vectors
to zero okay to the kind of zero origin
Point
um I'll convince you that this is true
in a minute just bear with me and so
this expression here this determinant
of a minus Lambda I
equals zero this is not true for all
Lambda remember I showed you in a couple
of lectures ago that this is actually
the characteristic polynomial
um
of our differential equation
this is a polynomial equation
a polynomial
polynomial equation
in Lambda and the roots are my
eigenvalues my eigen
values so the first thing I do is I
literally this is something I can write
down I can write down a I can write down
Lambda I I can write down this
determinant set it equal to zero I get a
polynomial and Lambda and I solve for
those lambdas where this is true for
those very specific lambdas if I have a
two by two a matrix I'll have two of
them if I have a three by three a matrix
I'll have three of them for those very
specific lambdas
then there are some x's that will map to
zero okay so um and I'll just remind you
that this is in fact exactly the
characteristic equation when we're
talking about differential equations
characteristic
equation when we're talking about
differential equations
okay good
I'll show you how this works on that
previous example and that two by two
system example but I want to remind you
how to compute the determinant of two by
two and three by three matrices and
things like that
um
so maybe the first thing I want to show
you is that the determinant
the determinant
of a matrix a
measures the volume
of a square after you map it through a
so how do I want to say this this
measures
the volume
of a unit cube of a unit
Cube
after
all of the sides get mapped through a
after all sides
are mapped
through I'm going to draw you a picture
don't worry through a so specifically if
I take like this example of a equals two
one one two
really simple a matrix what I mean by a
unit cube
is I literally take
a little unit Vector in the X1 Direction
This is X1 and a little unit Vector in
the X
two direction and I say that this is a
little you know in two Dimensions it's a
square in three dimensions it's a cube
in four dimensions it's a hyper Cube
um
so I take this you know Square in 2D or
a cube and ND and I map each of those
legs through this a matrix so my one
zero leg gets mapped to two
one so that goes from here to here so
this little leg gets mapped
uh
here okay my this Vector gets mapped to
here and this little vertical Vector 0 1
0 1 gets mapped to one two I take one
step over and two steps up and this is
that Vector there and you could also
take this little far corner here and map
it through and you'll find that you get
this kind of parallel
parallelogram and I drew a really bad
job of that parallelogram let's see if I
can make this not so horrible
not a perfectionist
but I do have standards
okay that's better
and so now if my original unit skew
square or cube had area one because it
had length one on all sides the area or
volume of this pink deformed uh
parallelogram is going to equal the
determinant of a and for a two by two
Matrix like this the determinant of a is
going to be the product of the first
main diagonal minus the product of the
second diagonal so that's four minus one
equals three so the area of this pink
parallelogram is equal to three it's
equal to the area that the determinant
of this a matrix
and so this is kind of how I want to
convince you
that when this thing has determinant
zero it's singular it means that I map
some directions to to zero what is the
only way that I could map these this
little yellow Square here to something
with zero area
the only way I could map it to something
with zero area is if these vectors map
to something parallel so this squished
together and had zero area
and what that means is that the only way
that these two vectors this
two-dimensional space can map into a
one-dimensional space with zero area is
if there is some direction that maps to
the origin that maps to zero okay that
means there's some Direction that's
getting collapsed and kind of smushed
out of this to give this zero area so
when my determinant is zero that means
that there are some directions that are
being obliterated uh then a times that
direction will equal zero some
directions are getting obliterated I'm
I'm losing Dimensions I'm going from two
Dimensions to one dimension that's the
only way this thing could have area zero
is if it's kind of one dimensional and
infinitely thin and so that's what I
mean here when I say that this Matrix
has determinant zero there are certain
directions certain X's that get
obliterated because this thing has area
zero when the determinant is equal to
zero
um I'll show you how to take the
determinant of a three by three Matrix
because I think that's important for you
to know
um so debt of a three by three Matrix
when I have let's say uh b11 B12
B13 B two one B two two
I'm gonna stop talking b23
I'm not going to stop talking
apparently
okay so the way you take this
determinant is again similar to this one
I'm going to take the first element
times the determinant of its
the two by two block where you omit the
first row and column that this b11 is in
so that's b11 times the determinant of
this thing which is uh b 2 2 B 3 3 minus
b 2 3 B 3 2.
okay there's that one minus
this guy times the determinant of its
sub block
if you omitted that row and that column
so that's
B12 times b 2 1 B 3 3 minus b 2 3 B
3 1.
and then finally plus let's pick a
different color maybe I'll do orange
Plus
b 1 3 times the determinant of this two
by two sub block that you get when you
omit this row and this column and that's
uh
B21 b32 minus
B22 b31 okay and if I had
I do the exact same thing and it's
recursive and it's horrible you take
this one times the sub block minus this
one times the sub block plus this one
times the sub block minus this one times
the sub lock and then for those sub
blocks you'd have to do the same thing
recursively and it becomes a real mess
but this is it for a
three by three Matrix and for a two by
two matrix it's trivial just product of
the diagonals minus product of the off
diagonals okay so that is what you need
you need to be able to compute these
determinants of these a minus Lambda I's
to get a polynomial it's going to be
some big nasty polynomial in Lambda and
then you're going to solve that
polynomial for its roots the lambdas
that make that equal to zero those are
your eigenvalues then we take those
eigenvalues plug them into here and find
out which X's get obliterated which X is
mapped to zero those are your
eigenvectors
okay I'm going to erase some stuff and
then we're going to do an example uh the
exact same example we did last time so
just stay put
okay we're going to uh now solve for the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors for that
same little two by two a matrix we
worked on before
so our example is uh a equals I think it
was three minus 1 minus one three
three minus 1 minus 1 3
. the first thing we do is we compute a
minus Lambda I take its determinant and
solve that characteristic polynomial
so
a minus Lambda times the identity is
easy this is just 3 minus Lambda minus 1
minus 1 3 minus Lambda
taking its determinant
debt of a minus Lambda I is just the
product of the diagonals
minus the product of the off diagonals
so this is a Lambda squared
minus 6 Lambda
plus nine
plus another one so plus 10 just slow
down and confirm that that's true and
this has to equal 0 for my eigenvalues
and so now you see that this is actually
just a simple polynomial equation so I
can
did I do this right
nope I totally didn't do this right
um
that was 9 minus a plus one which is
minus one so this should be an eight
okay that should be an eight so this is
plus eight and this is gonna be a lot
easier for me to do in my head so now I
factor this thing and this looks like uh
Lambda minus four
times Lambda minus two
equals zero just confirm that that you
know Lambda squared minus six Lambda
plus eight good and so Lambda equals two
and Lambda equals four are my
eigenvalues
good okay we're cooking with fire
now for Lambda 2 and Lambda 4 I'm going
to find the x that gets mapped to zero
those are going to be my eigenvectors so
this is pretty easy
um okay so let's just do this Lambda 1
equals two let's start with Lambda 2.
so now I take a
minus 2i
which is
um
a minus 2i is just 1 minus 1 minus 1 1.
and I'm trying to find the X Vector that
gets mapped to zero through that mapping
so I have you know 1 minus 1 minus 1 1
times X1 X2
okay that's going to equal X1
minus x 2 and minus X1
plus X2 and clearly if X1 equals X2 both
of these equal zero so X1 equals X2
um X1 and X2 could just be equal to one
one okay so that's an eigenvector I went
a little fast but I think you can
convince yourself I I tried to find the
x that would map you know for for x
equal for X1 equals X2 this maps to zero
if X1 and X2 were equal to each other
okay that's what I do here similarly for
Lambda 2 Lambda 2 equals 4.
uh a minus Lambda 2
minus sorry minus 4i a minus 4i is minus
1 minus 1 minus 1 minus 1. that's a
nasty one and minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
minus one very negative
um
that equals you know minus X1 minus x 2
minus X1 minus x two and so clearly here
as long as X2 is the opposite of X1 both
of these will equal to zero this will
equal zero if
X2 equals minus X1 and so I can say that
X1 X2
equals you know 1 negative one
is an eigenvector so this is an
eigenvector corresponding to Lambda 2
and this is an eigenvector corresponding
to Lambda 4. and these are exactly the
same eigenvectors this is you know C
2 and this is c 1 that we found before
okay good
um that's everything I wanted to show
you that was a big lecture uh we derived
how to how to find X and Lambda to
satisfy this eigenvalue equation they
are special vectors X and special
numbers Lambda so that if I multiply
that vector by a it doesn't rotate or
change directions it stays in exactly
the same X Direction and it gets scaled
bigger or smaller or maybe even flipped
negative by my eigenvalue Lambda and I
showed you some examples of how to do
this in the next lecture we're going to
use what we learned here and go back to
solving ordinary differential equations
thank you
[Music]
foreign